côté de moi un des papas le papa comment
on peut dire le premier le deuxième papa
de transit mis un peu le premier parce
que
d'abord il fallait l'idée de l'émission
installer l'idée du personnes at on
envie et puis ensuite donc je suis vite
allé chercher à la rescousse le deuxième
papa il allait dessiner fallait
fabriquer le personnage et même le faire
vivre puisque c'est yves qui a fait tous
à lui-même g christophe izard à côté de
moi il est donc le papa un des papas de
casimir alors une petite question
c'était quand à quelle heure ça a
commencé quand
aulas le tout début a commencé avec une
idée de jean louis guillaud qui voulait
reprendre
des extraits d'une émission américaine
et il voulait à côté une émission
française et il m'a demandé de m'occuper
de cette émission je n'avais jamais fait
d'émissions pour enfants et donc on a
commencé à gamberger c'était ça en 73
c'était sur la troisième chaîne de la
rtf 73 173 voilà et alors sami anan et
on a débuté en septembre 74 sur la
troisième chaîne mais regardez
à bonjour j'ai suivi alors casimir est
ce qu'on peut dire ce mot terrible est
ce qu'on peut dire que vous êtes à la
retraite
c'est une belle chose là est ce que
c'est la retraite cherche que l'on a
envie de faire quand on veut comme on
veut je vais vous dire je vous dire
quasiment vous n'êtes pas du tout à la
retraite vous allez voir comment vous
réclamez comme on vous aime on a été
dans la rue pour en parler vous allez
voir le résultat tout de suite adhéré
casimir souvent l'île aux enfants il ya
son cousin hippolyte ils mangent du
gloubiboulga oui je me souviens de ce
plat la confiture et au 6e plaque que
gémir
un mélange de saucisses confiture de
fraise et bananes je crois c'était la
potion magique de casimir si venus
me rappelle de tous les personnages
hippolyte léonard
casimir mademoiselle futé monsieur 10
nomme c'était un feuilleton pour enfants
c'était une espèce de bestioles qui
vivait dans un
village enchanté face à ces machins
jaune et à une formation et c'est un
dinosaure orange avec des petits pics
sur le dos et il est dans l'île aux
enfants et puis avait plein d'autres ces
iem et ses copains violet et tout je
rappelle c'était sur une émission avec
des nuages aux dinosaures faire moi je
veux en verre mais bon je suis pas en
ouest de télé en noir et blanc
c'est un bonhomme berne un gros bonhomme
vert avec des ronds dans la main le
nounours et 2
si dragon quoi c'était gentil et je
pense que c'était beaucoup mieux que les
dessins japonais actuel où il ya
beaucoup de violence pour les jeunes
ouais même y avait l'autre sa meuf là et
pas sa femme l'îlot bonheur là où lui du
bonheur les enfants ont pu beaucoup
d'occasions de regarder des choses comme
ça je trouve ça dommage j'ai entendu
parler d'une cassette vidéo j'aime bien
on pourquoi pas j'aimerais bien voir
vous allez à 13 ostalgiques ouais non
mais quasiment
mesdames messieurs je suis très heureux
parce que c'est la révolution dans
france 2 tous les gens qui travaillent
ici vous savez que nous sommes en direct
à l'espace matin qu' au rez de chaussée
de l'avenue montaigne et tous les gens
des bureaux au dessus de nous descendre
pour voir casimir ça fait plaisir
justement casimir et christophe izard
qu'est ce que ça fait onze ans après de
voir qu'on parle toujours autant de vous
ben c'est simple et émouvant parce que
finalement on fait rétrospectivement
qu'on se rend compte d'un du pouvoir que
l'on avait oui alors casimir j'ai une
petite question d'où venez vous en fait
là d'où je viens moi casimir oui ben je
viens de l'imagination d'un de
christophe issue présent et dindo yves
brunier malades d'accord est ce qu'on
peut donner votre avis que vous avez un
âge dans l'âge c'est l'âge de l'émission
vous êtes mis en 74 alors exactement
comment ça s'est passé et christophe à
quel point de vue parce que l'année
seule annonce la naissance de casimir
bas on a cherché on cherchait vraiment
un personnage auquel les enfants
puissent s'identifier là on vous fait un
tout petit un tout petit coin de
psychopédagogie non mais c'est important
mais c'est parce que on s'était rendu
compte que par rapport aux américains
qui font des programmes préscolaires
parce qu'il n'ya pas de maternelle
gratuite nous le problème en france
c'était le passage de la maternelle à
l'école où les enfants et se trouvaient
souvent dans une situation un peu
déséquilibré et donc il fallait un
personnage auquel ils puissent
s'identifier qui est leur âge et pour
qu'ils soient pas où un enfant ridicule
ou un adulte attardé etc on a cherché
différents caractères de personnages qui
va fait plusieurs dessins et on s'est
arrêtés très vite sur casimir dit on
peut dire que c'est un dinosaure comme
j'ai dit dans le sommaire jeu du marché
interne au sort c'est un dictionnaire
bâle iii lieu où je vais me faire battre
à
tout jeune dinosaure we made in his de
la dynastie des caisses imi russe des
casimir le salon justement pour louer
ligne et casimir est ce qu'il ya une
histoire à ce sujet pourquoi avoir
choisi casimir j'ai tout simplement pris
un calendrier je cherchais c'était la
saint casimir hier jacques gasser
absolument c'était la saint casimir
innerve on le fait avec un jour de
retard dans ma caméra et parlez nous de
votre maison de votre famille sur l'île
aux enfants comment ça se passe et
comment vous avez ressenti les choses
vous pendant huit ans ça a été
merveilleux c'est moi je pense que le
succès d'une émission ça tient à des
choses un petit peu magique et
indéfinissable par avance il s'est
trouvé que là c'est comme une mayonnaise
s'apprend ne s'apprend pas axa a pris
oui avec monsieur du snob julie françois
il ya eu une espèce on a pris un plaisir
fou à à s'amuser à jouer ensemble
c'était pas tous les jours drôle hein on
a relevé des des journées tournage bien
rempli très très chargé mais pas une
fois je pense en or 8 ans on s'est
ennuyé et puis on a en a arrêté je pense
parce qu on a craint alors que ça
n'existait pas on a peut-être dit mais
peut-être que si on continue encore dix
ans commencera à s'ennuyer lors on a
arrêté à ce moment là mais je pense
qu'on aurait peut-être plus encore
continuer autant ouais mais bon on va
voir ça tout à l'heure tout de suite on
va vous retrouver casimir dans vos
aventures avec tous vos amis dont vous
venez de parler qui seront avec nous
tout à l'heure sur ce plateau sur le
plateau de matin bonheur regarder un
petit medley des deux séquences l'île
aux enfants
quelle calamité cette fuite est le tarif
ils m'ont pour qu'elle dit mais j'ai
rencontré mademoiselle future renault
ici elle m'a obligé à faire trois fois
le tour de l'île en courant c'est ça que
j'ai perdu au moins 100 grammes alors tu
as eu droit à l'entraînement intensif de
mademoiselle futé oui bon je ne sais pas
ce qu'il lui a pris en plus de me
rabâcher sans arrêt que je mangeais trop
de gloubiboulga elle me faisait faire
toutes les cinq minutes des exercices
respiratoires
vas-y quasiment votre guerre lors voilà
je joue un sauf s'il n'est ce pas
qu'est ce que c'est
le football c'est ça qui est génial
c'est ça le football un autre aspect
beaucoup
jouer avec un ballon il joue au basket
au basketball c'était bizarre il dribble
et il met le ballon dans le panier alors
restez calme oui mais je je je suis
calme monsieur le chef de de la
publicité pendant le chef de la
publicité c'est toi ah oui oui oh pardon
monsieur le monsieur l'administrateur
venons encore raté pollitt
l'administrateur c'est moi ah bon
d'écouter les sont tombés tout ça et
appelons nous par nos prénoms comme
d'habitude moi je préfère un merci julie
bien tout est prêt christophe izard et
yves brunier vous nous avez rejoint
alors on vous voit dans vos oeuvres là
en casimir comment vous pouviez danser
chanter ce j'en sais quelque chose quand
on porte des costumes quand comment
c'était possible vous passez des heures
et des journées de tournage sous ce
costume ou ses ont répété
quand on avait un nouveau réalisateur
dont faisait un petit bout de répétition
avec le costume mais sinon des
répétitions se faisait comme ça on
imaginait le volume et puis je rentrais
de danse à sa durée de 5 minutes à 20
minutes maximum c'est vrai qu'il est le
plus difficile c'était effectivement les
danses et les chants saumon les chansons
étaient en playback quand même
heureusement et mais c'était bon j'ai
pris cette nuit kg quand j'ai arrêté
c'est un excellent tornare oui ça n'a
jamais été exporté il ya eu des des
produits dérivés n'y a jamais eu de
combinaisons amaigrissante on aurait pu
alors il ya énormément de questions qui
nous parviennent au standard il y en ad
il ya des anecdotes et pia il ya aussi
des questions profondes mais dans les
anecdotes sait combien ça ça fascine
combien y at il eu de costumes de
casimir ça c'est une question qui
revient tout le temps d'admirer perçait
ces résistants il le fut 106 108 en 680
comment ce comment se passait au
christophe oui comment se passaient les
tournages d'abord c'est et où l'île aux
enfants ça aussi ça ça revient quand on
a commencé à marseille parce que c'était
station régionale sur la troisième
chaîne de la rti lino enfants à d'abord
été à marseille absolument dans les ter
marseille dans les studios de la rtf à
marseille oui et puis quelques mois plus
tard quand le rtf a éclaté jean louis
guillaud qui devenait directeur général
de tf1 a voulu emmener l'île aux enfants
alors là on est revenu sur paris
quelques temps d'ailleurs à boulogne et
puis on est vite arrivé ça ça a été le
grand studio au studio de joinville où
on a tourné jusqu'à la fin de l'île aux
enfants alors l'île aux enfants quand le
soir le tournage s'arrêtait les lumières
étaient éteintes sur l'île aux enfants
de nos enfants est resté pendant huit
ans sur le même plateau absolument oui
c'était votre plateau c'était l'île aux
enfants et quels étaient les rapports on
voit les enfants en naviguant dans
l'extrait les enfants qui jouent autour
de vous quelles étaient vos rapports
casimir il brunier pardon avec les
enfants le rapport les enfants rentrer
dans le jeu immédiatement parce que la
crème qui avait au départ c'est que bon
il me voyait sortir transpirant rentrer
dans le costume et au départ y avait la
crainte d'y dire mais ça va complètement
brisé le rêve et c'est la magie aussi
l'enfance et que l'enfant ne rentrer
immédiatement dans le geste hier dès que
j'étais dans casimir casimir existait
était vivant et il s'adressait à casimir
et país brunet qu'ils avaient vu trois
minutes avant en dehors du costume ça
c'est le sait le mirage de l'enfant
c'est normal tout à fait il ya une
petite chose qu'il faut quand même
ajouté sur christophe sait que le décor
est resté huit ans donc à joinville mais
il restait encore près de six mois
supplémentaires parce que les
techniciens nous est pas le démonter et
tant qu'on n'a pas eu absolument besoin
de ce studio ils l'ont laissé en place
le plus longtemps possible ce qui prouve
quand même dans ce métier c'est rare ce
genre de choses il ya vraiment de bonnes
rondes autour de casimir puis on le voit
ici si vous voyez mesdames messieurs le
dieu sait si l'espace matin est petit
c'est noir de monde derrière les caméras
tout le monde est là pour voir iv pour
voir christophe ça fait vraiment plaisir
autre question en huit ans huit ans
c'est long pour une émission de
télévision est ce que le rôle de casimir
a évolué est ce que les enfants
christophe au niveau pédagogique je
crois qu'il y à casimir avait une
mission c'était pas gratuit ah non
c'était donc d'as de leur donner
confiance était essentiellement puisque
c'était destiné surtout aux enfants de
milieux défavorisés ou de situations des
familiales défavorisés qui avaient
besoin qu'ils arrivaient à l'école après
l'univers très protégé de la maternelle
donc on voulait d'abord leur donner
confiance et puis le ramener un certain
nombre d'idées de notions c'est on
faisait pas de la télévision éducative
on était toujours à l'affût de ce qui
pouvait être éducatif c'est à dire qu'on
ne s'appuyait pas sur une organisation
éducative mais dès qu'on pouvait
exploiter quelques choses ont exploité
et ça c'était sympa mais c'est vrai
qu'au fil des ans on est allé plus vers
le rythme plus vers la distraction parce
que évidemment les missions évoluer yves
et yves brunier et ce qui n'a pas été
difficile pour vous de vous détacher du
rôle de casimir ceci une question que
beaucoup de gens nous posent
non pas du tout parce qu'elle al'inverse
d'un du travail de comédien le métier de
marionnettiste moi j'appelle ça
marionnettiste soit des marionnettes à
gaine marionnettes à fils pour moi c'est
le même métier il ya dès le départ un
dédoublement c'est à dire quand on
rentre dans la peau d'un personnage on
devient instantanément ce personnage et
on en sort on est immédiatement autre
chose avec un comédien qui ce qui subit
parfois presque une transformation
physique s'intègre plus un rôle mais le
la marionnette un personnage comme
casimir permet de se dédoubler
instantanément ce qui fait que je je
devenais en une minute casimir
richebourg et niais sans aucun problème
et il faut reconnaître aussi que ce qui
était frappant c'est que dans la rue
quand on se promenait merveille bricard
qui était un peu françois juni et
brunier qui était casimir les enfants se
précipiter vers les comédiens les autres
comédiens ou du snob et à ce moment là
ils disaient mais où et casimir alors on
disait pas le voilà
je crois que ea vous allez devoir
malheureusement nous quitter parce que
votre vous avez vous êtes un artiste
vous continuez vous continuez la
profession qu'est ce que vous faites
tient en ce moment je travaille sur
canal plus sûres
une émission quotidienne qui s'appelle
canal+ émission aussi pour enfants bien
sûr oui et vous faites quoi dedans un
corbeau
fait encore beaucoup parler du dinosaure
au gua l'un et l'autre corbeau c'est
gérard cas - monaco l'élite voilà on
s'est retrouvés sont retrouvés dans un
air près vous faites toujours équipe
mais très bien eh ben on va voir
maintenant à des intermèdes avoir des
petits intermèdes les intermèdes qu'il y
avait dans casimir regardez tout de
suite et on revient tout de suite après
[Musique]
bonjour les bouilles
je ne me souviens plus de l'animal qui
me fait le plus peur vous vous souvenez
vous réfléchissez est assez curieux
quand on a peur généralement ne
réfléchit pas
[Musique]
à la tâche
je suis anti vol l'oiseau au sol
dit antivol si on jouait à pigeon vole
pigeon vole je vais t'expliquer je vais
citer des noms d'objets ou d'animaux et
chaque fois que je donnerai le nom de
quelque chose qui volent tu dois lever
la patte entendu je ne trouve pas ça
très passionnant mais enfin allons-y
comment vous ne me connaissez pas je
suis pourtant là depuis très longtemps
bon je ne vous en veux pas et je me
présente philibert le globule comme vous
pouvez le constater je suis un oiseau
d'une espèce très rare je suis
d'ailleurs le seul membre de la famille
des globules vivent sur cette île et
vous ne me croirez peut-être pas mais
malgré cela personne ne vient jamais me
rendre visite
[Musique]
allô allô c'est la noiraude je voudrais
parler aux vétérinaires
allô bonjour docteur la noiraude à
l'appareil
pas encore je dois partir en bulgarie en
bulgarie qu'est ce que vous avez fait
rempli carry on m'a demandé de faire du
yaourt au bout bulgares alors je dois
faire un stage en bulgarie ça vous
changera les idées la noiraude un petit
voyage mais je ne parle pas un mot de
bulgares je vais me sentir à comprise
dépaysé il être une alchimie griffe
touba oui il faut que tu cesses de
compter sur les autres pour tous tu as
l'âge de prendre des responsabilités du
train tu as perdu ton la panne y est
bien cherché le toi même à bout gauchy
tu sais que tu as un vrai ami tu me
donne toujours de très très bons
conseils je te remercie oh oui je te
remercie il n'y a vraiment pas de quoi
ça fera cinq francs
yves brenier tellement bien avec nous
qu'il n'a pas voulu partir il reste
encore cinq minutes et bien voilà
regarder qui j'ai à côté de moi regardez
bonjour eliane gauthier julie vaux quand
allez vous
préviens
bonjour patrick bricka oui françois
france pour moi je vous ai tellement
françois c'est ce qui m'amuse c'est que
ce matin vous avez une chemise qui
ressemble un peu à celle que portait
france aux autres c'est vrai
c'est un hommage
était rendu bonjour messieurs du snav
alors très bien c'est bien de rajouter
monsieur parce que christophe dit
toujours du snop ce qui est vraiment
très humiliant pour moi du sud on peut
voir l'enregistrement de talent heure-là
il a dit plusieurs fois et les messieurs
ont fait un petit coucou à mademoiselle
futé au facteur je prends un facteur clé
dans le midi il n'a pas pu voir avec
nous il a de la chance alors qu'est ce
que c'était si internet qu'on vient de
voir alors ça c'est est ce qu'on
appelait nous les séquences
intercalaires qui était destinée à
couper un peu l'émission le plateau pour
que relancer l'attention et aussi à être
parfois un clin d'oeil pour les les plus
grands de façon à ce que l'émission soit
pas un ghetto pour les tout petits alors
des séquences comme la vache noire
autres comme anti vol était déçu quand
la machine a rod a eu beaucoup de succès
parce que quand on a préparé l'émission
il ya beaucoup de jeunes dans l'équipe
de matin bonheur j'ai entendu pendant
une semaine la vache noire à lola
et je crois que nous avons le téléphone
le téléphone n'arrête pas de sonner à
matin bonheur nous avons un appel je
crois que sandrine est en ligne bonjour
sandrine bonjour est ce que je peux je
peux vous demander votre âge sandrine a
generation casimir
vous l'île aux enfants est avec nous
alors vous pouvez poser votre question
envie de voir j'adore il faut regarder
que je regardais quand j'étais tout
petit et je me souviens qu'un jour je
rentrais de l'école mes parents va aller
la télé couleur et j'ai regardé pour la
première fois qu'elle y mirent en
couleur j'ai trouvé un malric les
couleurs le vert le rouge le jaune
orange et je suis vraiment
oui vous êtes ému et justement à ce
propos christophe me disais tout à
l'heure que on voyait casimir vers tous
les gens qui l'avaient en noir et blanc
général le voyez vert et ont été surpris
à près de le découvrir orange est ce que
c'était votre cas
mais bon pour moi la couleur quand les
couleurs ça a été vraiment mal et ça a
été le choc
je voudrais
tout de suite mais déjà romaine qui sont
là des usa
merci beaucoup sandrine de votre
témoignage crois que ça nous touche
beaucoup ça touche beaucoup tous nos
amis sur le plateau est ce qu'on va
revoir merci sandrine de nous avoir
rappelé en or voir est ce que est ce que
on va peut-être voir casimir un jour
c'est possible on n'en sait rien du tout
de toute façon c'est pas nous qui
pouvons dire je crois que quand on est
où comédiens ou acteurs on a toujours
envie d'être vue de repasser mais c'est
aux responsables de la chaîne ou des
chaînes qu'il faut poser cette question
très bien si si il y a encore des gens
qui ne vous connaissent pas je dis bien
s'il y en a encore est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter rapidement vous
présenter en tant que personnage de
l'île aux enfants julie c'était qui
julie bat julie c'était
john gotti déjà d'abord et
toujours eliane gauthier
et puis
c'était effectivement quelque chose que
un personnage que j'ai complètement
essayé de coller à moi mais la
caractéristique à la baisse et quelle
était la grande soeur de casimir mais
elle faisait des bêtises comme lui et ça
les enfants adoraient françois c'était
conflit et elle se mettait en colère
souvent les enfants me disait on adore
quand tu te mets en colère et ça et
quand tu fais des bêtises donc ça
c'était une notion importante c'était
des bêtises oui c'était toujours très
raisonnable oui très raisonnable et
beaucoup de tendresse un personnage très
tendre avec et qu'est ce qu'ils avaient
dans votre kiosque
l art y avait le tunnel de léonard et
vous chers l'avenir
de la zone euro n'a oui oui dans lequel
je tombais de temps en temps art il
avait oublié de fermer la trappe
il y avait d'autres puis on va y avait
toutes mes petites affaires parce que
j'ai toujours des gros stack avec plein
de choses de danse des bonbons
dans des grands beaucoup dehors il
n'était pas dedans ce qu'il faut dire
pour
julie donc la marchande de bonbons c'est
que je voyais pas du tout un personnage
comme il y adjoignant un personnage
beaucoup plus sérieux et puis le jour où
eliane est venu me voir dans mon bureau
pour auditionner donc je l'avais jamais
vu encore et je lui ai demandé comment
on fait un curriculum vitae des photos
etc et à ce moment là je l' ai vu
plonger dans un énorme sac où elle a
disparu y avait des débris qui volaient
dans tous les sens et j'ai trouvé le
personnage tellement drôle que j'ai
décidé d'en de coller ça et de et que ça
serait désormais le personnage de julie
et bien avant de parler avec françois et
monsieur du snob nous allons revoir un
petit medley de casimir regarder au
revoir yves cette fois
il m'est très chère amie ma très chère
amie soyez la bienvenue soyez la
bienvenue
bon sang casimir
j'ai prévenu françois est le facteur il
devrait arriver à ces parfaits léonard
merci et nous sommes un jour
du synode est mort du sida en chine vous
plaît s'il vous plaît j'ai
versé 1000
j'ai l'honneur avantage de vous
présenter
toujours plus loin toujours plus fort
dans mes sculptures ou
voici pour dernier chef-d'oeuvre
je mentais bon ça va pas du tout et le
bocal là mais oui mais moi je peux
retrouver avec le petit lapin rose jeu
ça va pas du tout du tout bonjour
monsieur duchesneau mais je l'aimé tant
a cassé mais jean de manger une comtesse
leuthard
il comptait encore ses comptes est
imaginaire non mais c'est toujours la
même chose c'est toujours quand on a
besoin de lui il a un rendez vous
important et moi je ne supporte plus ses
comptes est imaginaire
une petite foule et les enfants
là ça y est on est arrivé bravo à vous
étiez en super forme aujourd'hui et bien
maintenant vous allez prendre une bonne
douche et on se retrouve tout à l'heure
d'accord
sarah kazemy oui très mal merci à
laurent que t'arrive t il encore je ne
supporte plus les contextes de monsieur
du soir avoue enfin casimir tu sais très
bien que c'est conteste n'existe pas
mais justement c'est ça qui m'agace
parce que tu voudrais sans doute
qu'elles existent mais non je ne veux
plus jamais entendre parler des comptes
est le monsieur du snob bonjour bonjour
cassini
tu sais on est toujours de bonne humeur
quand on va faire une bonne action ça
c'est très vrai et s est vu l'action eh
bien j'ai décidé de vous faire un cadeau
à tous les trois parce que vous êtes
tellement gentil avec moi mais c'est
qu'on t'aime beaucoup casimir le faisons
là rien d'extraordinaire
mais si si si j'y tiens beaucoup et puis
ça me fait tellement plaisir mais
dis-moi casimir pourquoi aujourd'hui
sans aucune raison a si justement il y a
une très bonne raison laquelle eh bien
j'ai tout rangé chez moi et j'ai
retrouvé des objets dont je ne savais
pas quoi faire alors au lieu de les
jeter à la poubelle j'ai pensé vous les
donnez vous avez demandé quelque chose
un éclair au chocolat
voilà aux farceurs tu me fais peur
pour moi petite balle j'aimerais que tu
me prépares un bon gloubiboulga séance
j'avais complètement oublié et là
horreur du gloubiboulga
ne soit pas trop triste casimir nous
allons partager avec les vrais pas vous
vous êtes le véritable ami en lui un
grand saladier oui tout de suite nous
allons partager mais bien sûr vite passe
à la fois oui à la tiens
voilà voilà
le sandwich au jambon
bonjour les termes des milliers on peut
faire un gloubi boulga avec la bête
qu'on met même menu mais nous
sommes et nous allons partager
casimir
[Applaudissements]
voilà matin bonheur reçoit ce matin
l'île aux enfants il ya des discussions
sur le plateau c'est vrai que 1
que de souvenirs oui
alors françois qui étiez vous eh bien je
crois que dans l'esprit de christophe
l'auteur le pape a tous les personnages
moi je représentais un petit peu le
grand frère des enfants peut-être aussi
un petit peu le papa sans que ce soit à
100 que ce soit dit vraiment et dans cet
univers dans lequel il y avait pas mal
de de délire j'étais un petit peu
l'élément raisonnable et les mots
modérateur et quand vraiment la coupe
déborde et un petit peu j'étais là pour
me par contre ce que j'aimais beaucoup
aussi c'est à côté de ce personnage
je pouvais mais aussi délirer à travers
le beaucoup de personnages de
composition qu'avait christophe bérardi
moi je me sentais un peu comme un grand
frère ben voilà c'est ce que c'est ce
que je vous disais donc il a réussi il a
réussi son corps et en voilà six ans
alors monsieur du snob oui jean louis
terreau angles oui qui étiez vous
le personnage principal de l'île aux
enfants
non casimir est une marionnette n'est
qu'une marionnette oui à on l'a vu un
objet d'ailleurs on le voit d'ailleurs
nous dit il n'était pas un original et
je me suis non et je ne suis pas sûr
numéro non plus et j'étais le personnage
principal c'est sa valeur peut être à
petit j'ai grignoter j'étais un
personnage secondaire puis petit à petit
bon voila j'ai réussi à devenir le
personnage principal plus intéressant à
mon avis intéressant parce que
franchement il était trop bon c'est vrai
il faisait rire autant les tout petits
que les plus grands alors que les autres
des bonds lui n'était pour les petits et
bien pour les petits
léonard pour les trayons moi j'étais
pour tout le monde même les mamies me
voyais d'ailleurs j'ai les mamies dans
la rue qui me disent vous me rappelait
mon enfance
houston n'a pas changé il nous le prouve
il ya une question qui revient
énormément aux standards et je sais que
dans l'équipe de matin bonheur on m'a
dit surtout tu la pause celle là c'est
qu'ils étaient julie pour françois alors
sa question vient
alors oui je n'ai pas tenir dit au
départ
non parce que de toute façon
l'émission avait été écrite comme je les
dis pour aider les enfants qui
arrivaient à l'école donc à se sentir
mieux dans cet univers un peu compliqué
donc il y avait aucune structure
familiale y avait pas de parents il ya
personne n'était ni mariée ni la seule
structure familiale c'était casimir et
son cousin hippolyte mais alors il y
avait julien de fond soir et alors là ce
qui était intéressant c'est qu'il ya des
enfants qui les mariés d'autres qui on
faisait le frère et la soeur c'était une
sorte si je peux me permettre de perdre
espagnols
m'ont amené la structure familiale qu'on
a qu'on anglais les enfants se poser des
questions et moi il m'est même arrivé
choses assez assez rigolote que des
enfants traînent ma femme qui est toute
blonde pour julie dans la rue
ah oui donc on allait je crois que les
enfants ont pensé pendant longtemps même
si elle est à présent hors
antenne un petit sketch ou si julie
attendait un enfant le jour de
l'accouchement dans le kiosque il y
avait là plus y avait léonard casimir
hippolyte
snom et le facteur qui attendaient pour
savoir à qui il appartenait à
tout ça ne regardez pas les enfants
alors une autre caisse avec qui écrivait
les scénarii qui écrit parce que une
émission par jour vous tourniez dans les
conditions du direct je présume ah non
non non non non non on reprenait on
travaillait on avait un système de deux
répétitions deux jours de répétition
trois jours de tournage et dans lesquels
on ont tourné à peu près 25 minutes mais
en huit heures de tournage est vraiment
avec des reprises alors pour bien faire
ce battage combien faire ce genre
d'émission et de travail il faut écrire
qui écrivait au début ça a été moi qui
ai écrit les premiers épisodes et puis
très rapidement
après quand même une centaine d'épisodes
j'ai eu un peu à peu le renfort des
comédiens parce que c'était eux qui
était le mieux placé pour écrire des
histoires aussi patrick vous avez donc
il ya eu
ça c'était exceptionnel parce que on
pouvait se faire plaisir à dire que
pendant le tournage on se dit tiens la
prochaine fois je ferai bien un hommage
à tati
chaplin tiens je ferais bien des on se
passerait bien des tartes à la crème bon
je tomberai bien habillé dans une
piscine ou tiens on va faire un truc par
rapport aux enfants sur telle pédagogie
chaque fois qu'on aimerait visiter une
usine réaliser vos rêves alors les
examens mais ce que je l'ajouté aussi
c'est pâques avec nous écrivions les uns
les autres nous nous écrivions par
forcément pour nous même des choses
carrées extraordinaire mais bon moi je
me tiens du stop je verrai bien de
l'événement monsieur et c'est un ouvrier
e eliane alors tout à l'heure vous avez
entendu le générique de votre émission
chanté par des fans génération casimir
on va dire ça faut que ça rentre dans le
dans le langage et peggy nous a rejoint
alors peggy je crois que vous avez créé
vous faites partie d'une association
pour le retour de casimir de l'île aux
enfants la télévision
après une émission on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait beaucoup de monde quand
même qu'il réclame et on a décidé
une pétition et puis on dans les rues à
la sortie des émissions osé signer les
pétitions qu'on va adresser à l'ina et
au csa pour débloquer les droits pour
que ça passe à la télévision parce que
ça va passer en cassette vidéo mais on
nous a dit que ce serait des best-of ne
veut pas de best-of on les veut
entièrement est tous très bien bravo si
on veut signer c'est à dire qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour signer cette
pétition pour le retour de casimir ah
bah déjà pour ceux qui arrivent pas qui
ne sont pas à paris parce qu'ils peuvent
nous croiser dans les rues mais de ceux
qui sont pas à paris peuvent nous écrire
très bien alors vous avez une adresse
vous écrivez à matin bonheur à l'adresse
36 15 codes france 2 on mettra tout sur
le minitel rubrique matin bonheur voilà
est bien triste ofisa revoilà l'adresse
qui s'affiche pour les fans de deux
matins et de casimir de vie de nos
enfants christophe vous n'avez pas fait
que l'île aux enfants et casimir vous ai
fait d'autres choses et nous allons le
découvrir tout de suite regardé ces
images
voici venu le temps des rires et des
chants dans l'île aux enfants c'est tous
les jours le printemps et oui cela fait
plus de dix ans maintenant que ce doux
générique qui émerveilla toute une
génération d'enfants aujourd'hui adultes
a disparu de notre petit écran fini les
facéties de se tendre et imposants
dinosaures à la robe orange du nom de
casimir fini les dégustations de
gloubiboulga mot de code d'un univers
qui n'existe plus quand nos mémoires
mais derrière casimir et son île aux
enfants il y à un homme son nom izard
son prénom christophe et ce merlin
l'enchanteur des programmes jeunesse est
unique en son genre
d'origine bretonne normand d'adoption
une fois son bac philo en poche il est
journaliste critique de jazz et écrivain
à l'époque la télévision s'appelle
encore le rte et de 68 à 71 il produit
une émission au titre évocateur à la
fiche du monde
1972 est une date importante pour ce
prince du divertissement pédagogique
c'est à ce moment là qu'il commence a
consacré sa carrière aux enfants et la
télévision lui demande de réfléchir à
une émission pour les enfants c'est
ainsi que naîtra l'île aux enfants avec
le tendre et maladroit casimir un
monstre gentil intervenants comme un
conseiller et un ami dans une île où
personne ne le pouvoir christophe izard
à des clubs de psychologues de
conseiller et de pédagogue planchent sur
ce qui reste un modèle du genre une
émission qui divertit qui éveille
l'enfant qui n'incitait être curieux en
un mot qui lui fait découvrir tous les
aspects de ce qu'est la vie et le monde
par le ludique puis à l'instar de
l'atlantide lit de ses enfants heureux
son bras dans les flots des changements
de programme nous laissant tous
orphelins heureusement le village dans
les nuages 20 combler ce vide troupe de
temps hélas mais comme il en faut plus
pour décourager christophe izard il
mettra sur pied c'est l'unique est la
première coproduction entre walt disney
company et intelligence européenne il
dirige l'unité jeunesse de la 2d 88 à 89
isa arts vous l'aurez compris c'est un
homme pas tout à fait comme les autres
qui préparent des émissions pas comme
les autres pour les enfants comme les
autres les enfants loin de la génération
nourrie aux entrepôts faljic dessins
animés nippons des enfants qui grâce à
lui grandissent dans la poésie et le
respect de l'autre
[Musique]
m'a dit l'on dit le très joli portrait
alors christophe comment passe-t-on de
journalistes de jazz à producteur
d'émissions pour enfants par un long
circuit c'est à dire le jazz d'abord à
jazz magazine puis la variété et le
music hall à france soir une grande
chance c'est que ça s'est passé dans les
années 60 la rue donc j'étais
responsable de la rubrique music hall et
10 cartron soir dans toute la plus
grande période yéyé on doit tout les
sixties et puis naturellement l'arrivée
à la télé par le magazine dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure qui est à lettres
qui était à la fiche du monde que je
faisais avec l'autre critère et puis des
variétés cros était déjà c'était un des
reportages sur les variétés à travers le
monde et puis le journal télévisé des
émissions de variétés télévisée louis
dans la l'époque deux des gros pains
formation première en 70 71
puis c'est comme ça d'ailleurs en allant
faire un reportage sur les
conservatoires de province que j'ai
rencontré jean louis mathieu duchesne et
gérard cac - qui est devenu hippolyte
ensuite et ça a été une des raisons leur
entrée dans l'île aux enfants et puis la
troisième chaîne en variété et puis ce
début un coup de la rencontre
un ami qui m'a demandé si je voulais
faire l'adaptation d'un programme
américain pour enfants dès 6 mdt le
sésame street première expérience pour
enfants puis casimir et alors là je n'ai
plus quitté les amis alors je crois
qu'il ya eu
dans l'ordre il faut il faut me dire si
je me trompe les visiteurs du mercredi
alors y ait eu l'île aux enfants
après les visiteurs du mercredi je me
suis pas trompé et après armes et
bagages dans les nues le village dans
les nuages salué les mickeys âmes
zappeurs salue les mickeys c'était 20h30
c'était 20h38 c'est ça et j'ai lu j'ai
lu dans la presse un article qui vous
était consacrée je voulais vous demander
si c'était votre devise ça vous est
attribué on s'amuse on chante et on
réfléchit
oui je crois que c'est quand même bien
parce que je crois que quand on est
responsable
d'un certain nombre d'heures d'émissions
quand on s'adresse à des millions
d'enfants je crois que d'abord ce qu'il
faut c'est l'excès rire les qui
s'amusent con que ce soit drôle hein il
s'agit pas du tout d'être ennuyeux mais
on n'a pas le droit de
de ne pas avoir dans un coin de sa tête
une petite notion de responsabilité
vis-à-vis d'eux donc l'idée pas de les
éduquer mais de les enrichir très bien
et outre julie françois monsieur du snob
je crois que vous avez découvert patrick
sabatier
[Rires]
oui non c'est vrai que les visiteurs du
mercredi ont saisi cornes allain
bougrain dubourg puis nicolas hulot l'a
eu
a expliqué nous la rottée mais elle est
épaisse elle sait elle était passée
avant déjà chez jacqueline joubert ben
je crois que des émissions pour la
jeunesse comme l'était le mercredi et
les visiteurs du mercredi qu'ils
faisaient quand même quatre heures et
demie avec beaucoup de direct à l'époque
c'était pas c'était pas des
enchaînements de dessins animés donc il
fallait des animateurs et ont cherché
dans les jeunes et puis bon ensuite une
fois qu'ils avaient fait ça un certain
temps ils partaient vers d'autres
horizons
vient alors qu'est ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui et bien aujourd'hui va d'une
part je fais une émission qui est
présenté par une sorte de dingue ça
passe le samedi matin ça s'appelle un à
barbaira ding dong est bon pour ça il
fallait que je trouve un d'un vrai
dingue alors il s'appelle l'uqam est
libre semble énorme franchement
et donc et je dois dire que ça marche
bien ça ça fonctionne bien et on en a
encore pour un an et demi et puis en
dehors de ça lui plaît pas du tout
d'ailleurs j'en ai encore pour un an et
demi
bah tant pis pour lui je lui parlerai
demain et puis en dehors de ça je fais
je produis
pour une société qui s'appelle france
animation qui est une des grosses
sociétés je dirais même européenne de
dessins animés nous faisons des grosses
séries de dessins animés france sa base
française avec des co producteurs
européens notamment la bbc où les
allemands de ravensburger et créateurs
vous avez créé notamment un dessin animé
vous allez nous en faire cas le cadeau
de l'exclusivité des premières images ça
va passer sur france 2 je ne sais pas
quand sur france 3 3 6 heures comme on
veut bah ça c'est une série qu'on a créé
complètement dans ce studio qui est
réalisé soit france animation paris à
paris réalisé par alain sion qui est
vraiment un réalisateur que j'ai
découvert là bas qui est un type
extraordinaire les dessins sont des gens
caillons qui est un type qui travaillait
aussi dans ce studio et toute l'équipe
du studio de montreuil puisqu'on est à
montreuil a participé à ça créé ce
produit sur lequel était quand même
entré en coproduction la bbc ce qui est
exceptionnel d'avoir des angles c'est un
dessin animé on peut dire que c'est un
des cinq français et vous allez voir les
images superbes ça s'appelle le
cinquième mousquetaire alors en amour
guide l'idée c'est que le alex ne
s'appelle pas le cinquième mousquetaire
ccc albert les cinquième mousquetaire
mais je voulais juste dire en préambule
que c'est que l'idée c'est qu'alexandre
dumas s'est trompé les trois
mousquetaires n'était pas quatre mais
cinq et il y avait quatre imbéciles
qu'ils seront ceux qu'on connaît et qui
ont dû leur gloire au cinquième qu'on ne
voyait jamais et qui est albert qu'on va
découvrir et cette fois nous voyons le
cinquième mousquetaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un message pour monsieur de tréville
capitaine des mousquetaires
rapport
un message pour moi
[Musique]
et c'est le saut dans l'arène
oh
ah bonjour capitaine est ce que la vie
est belle excusez moi une seconde encore
un jaune d'oeuf et ça sera parti un long
albert l'heure n'est pas aux aubes let
peut-être pas mais ça ne vous empêche
pas d'en faire une pourtant capitaine
[Musique]
pendant que vous plaisantez la france
est littéralement l'état de choc et ont
malgré cela vous garder le coeur à
manger comme il ya selon moi je ne mange
pas à capital non non pas du tout ce
sont mes nouvelles munitions
je viens d'inventer le tromblon à
spaghetti bolognaise
[Musique]
regardez ce mannequin là bas
vous excusez moi capitaine une toute
petite erreur de viser personne n'est
parfait vous savez bien que je vous
excuse toujours au bon petit qu'albert
fameuse votre choix
le cinquième mousquetaire en exclusivité
les premières images s'était jamais
passé à la télé ça passera sur france 3
dans combien de temps à peu près dans un
an dans un an ben alors on était
vraiment en exclusivité si christophe
alors on a parlé de ce que faisait
christophe à l'heure actuelle après lui
nos enfants joli qu'est ce que vous
faites maintenant à plein de choses bon
bah je continue à être comédien je
continue un entraînement professionnel
de danse parce que j'aimerais bien
reprendre la comédie musicale c'est
comme ça que j'ai commencé
et puis j'écris vous avez vu danser tout
à l'heure oui avec casimir exactement et
puis j'ai écrit
trois livres au nom même en chantier
la méthode de john strasberg qui est le
fils de lee strasberg avec lequel je
travaille wii select horse toujours oui
l'acteur studio fils ou fille voilà
junior quand j'ai dit à un belge
actuellement et puis à feuilles tombent
sur la vie de mademoiselle de normand
qui était une grande voyante du xviiie
siècle passionnés de vaulion ce sont les
vies oui énormément mais
et puis justement dans cette ligne là un
livre sur l'histoire des cartes
la tradition d'où viennent comment les
cartes ont été créés
vous viendrez en reparler qu'on s'en
sortira dans notre bonheur on
vous recevra avec plaisir je pense très
bien patrick oui françois j'ai du mal à
dire battre et je suis habitué qu'est ce
que vous faites maintenant eh bien je
suis depuis depuis longtemps retourner à
mes premières amours le théâtre enfin
tout ça c'est un petit peu la même chose
quand même donc je suis toujours
comédien mais je suis aussi et de plus
en plus metteur en scène
chose qui me passionne tout à fait mais
dense voilà alors je monte je travaille
beaucoup pour une compagnie qui
s'appelle les éclats théâtre qui a
provocation de jouer pour tout public et
aussi bien sûr les enfants les jeunes et
je monte beaucoup de classiques je monte
molière
le médecin malgré lui je monte des
spectacles sur jean de la fontaine le
roman de renart voir où et cetera et
cetera tirer bat très bientôt au théâtre
de la porte saint-martin en matinée
parfois en soirée est aussi retourné un
petit short ne loupez pas françois
monsieur du snob oui
jean louis angles oui ce que je fais
écouter savent vous avez du temps parce
que j'ai beaucoup de non dits et toucher
entre 1,9 alors je fais des choses
passionnantes je vais en dire que depuis
je travaille au festival d'avignon oui
voilà j'ai une responsabilité une grande
responsabilité au festival d'avignon et
qu'est ce que je peux dire d'autre je
m'occupe aussi de d'associations
humanitaires
pour moi que je partage ma vie entre les
deux et petit à petit je crois que je
finirais dans l'humanitaire parce que je
trouve que c'est urgent de notre temps
de s'occuper un peu des autres de ceux
qui en ont besoin donc voilà bien la
voix douce à vous tous bonne chance
[Musique]